[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon good morning and good
evening to everyone watching around the
world I'm delighted to open and welcome
you to the coronavirus global response
pledging event I believe the 4th of May
2020 will mark a turning point in our
fight against the corona virus because
today the world is coming together
government's from every continent will
join hands and team up with global
health organizations and other
experienced partners the partners are
many the goal is one to defeat this
virus the pandemic is affecting every
single country in the world
it has brought heartache and heartbreak
pain and suffering to millions of people
it has put enormous strain on health
care and welfare systems across the
globe it has shut down public life in
many parts of the world keeping us away
from our families our friends and the
things we love it has badly hit our
economies putting jobs livelihood and
businesses at risk
but it has also brought the best out of
humanity our our modern-day heroes are
now our health care workers small acts
of solidarity love and kindness are
spreading around the world and this
virus has reminded us that we have to
protect each other if we want to protect
ourselves the reality is that we will
have to learn to live with the virus
until and unless we develop a vaccine
and this is why we have to join forces
and pull our money and our minds to
kick-start work on vaccines diagnostics
and treatments against coronavirus we
need to develop produce and deploy them
to every single corner of the world and
we must ensure that they are available
and affordable for all and this is why
we must all chip in to finance this
truly global endeavor so our first
objective is to raise an initial sum of
7.5 billion euros or 8 billion dollars
this is the funding that is needed right
now to ramp up work on vaccines
diagnostics and treatments but more will
be needed so today is only the start of
a global pledging marathon the second
objective is to bring under the same
roof all global health organizations
working on initiatives to fight the
pandemic together we offer to the world
of framework for global cooperation on
vaccines diagnostics and therapeutics I
am so grateful to all the governments
that are joining us to present their
pledges particularly to the g20
presidency Saudi Arabia for its tireless
work to place this issue high on the g20
agenda
and to reach out to make today's event
successful I'm also grateful to the
other countries that are co-leading this
effort together with the European Union
Thank You France Germany Japan Norway
Canada Italy Spain and the United
Kingdom I'm also delighted that
experienced global health organizations
and foundations join forces with us they
bring valuable expertise and strength
and now let's give them the resources
they need let's start the pledging and
I'm delighted to get the ball rolling by
announcing the European Commission's
contribution the European Commission
mobilizes 1 billion euros for the
coronavirus Global Response and this is
a team Europe effort I'm pleased to
introduce the European councils
President shall mission shall you have
the floor Jerusalem I would like to join
Abdullah in thanking you warmly for your
participation today only a shared spirit
of double solidarity and responsibility
will defeat the 1219 crisis this common
spirit is our best defense against a
virus that has devastated lives and
communities in every corner of the globe
people are fighting the virus on every
continent different countries have
responded with different measures but we
all have one thing in common only the
development production and deployment of
vaccines and treatments will relegate
the virus to the archives of history
without these we can demand the hardest
sacrifices from our citizens or design
the most ambitious we have replaced the
threat will always be there
these vaccines treatments and therapies
will be crucial for Europe but even more
critical for our most vulnerable
partners with fragile health systems
such as Africa they must be at the heart
of our solidarity the picture is not all
bridge across history human beings have
displayed a surprising capacity to
innovate and bounce back from disaster
over the next month
great minds in laboratories across the
world will join forces to defeat the
virus they are doing so as we speak but
victory will take more than great minds
it will take focus it will take strong
international cooperation on vaccines
every step of the way it will also take
a firm commitment to multilateral
institutions and it will take resources
7.5 billion euros just to kick-start our
efforts it may seem like a lot but the
cost of inaction would be far greater
both in lives and resources the scope of
our response must match the scope of the
crisis today we have a clear goal to
accelerate the development manufacture
and delivery of vaccines tests and
treatments to everyone everywhere at an
affordable price these are dark days but
there are also days that we will our
humanity we are confident humanity will
step up and shine this pledging summit
is a confident step in that direction
thank you thank you shall today indeed I
hope that we are really demonstrating
the power of global community and who
could better represent the international
community than the United Nations I have
the pleasure to welcome the
secretary-general of the United Nations
joining us from New York Antonio
Guterres
Antonia thank you for being with us you
have the floor thank you so it's
enormous pleasure to be here and I say
to you pian Commission and its partner
governments for their leadership in
hosting these important pledging
conference this is exactly the kind of
leadership the world needs today in the
span of a few short months covered 19's
spread to every corner of the world in
fact more than 3.3 million people and
claiming more than 230,000 lives
comprehensive coordinated public health
measures are critical to sure
transmission and to save lives but even
countries that have taken such steps
remain in jeopardy and the virus is
still likely to strike many countries
that are least able to cope in an
interconnected world none of us is safe
until all of us are safe I was very
happy to join the robust organization
and an initial group of our sectors to
launch the a CT accelerator landmark
global cooperation to speed up
development production and equitable
access to the new carbon 19 Diagnostics
therapeutics and vaccines these new
tools can help us to fully control the
pandemic and must be treated as global
public goods available and affordable
for all this is the only path to a world
free of carbon 19 but these will require
the most massive public alpha us effort
in history today we are taking the next
step
mobilizing resources for this vital
endeavor and I welcome the generous
contributions being announced today
towards the initial goal of 7.5 billion
euros these funds are a kind of a down
payment for development the new tools at
the speed needed but to reach everyone
everywhere we likely need five types of
data mountains and I call on all
partners to join in this effort as we
look together again on late May to
sustain our momentum we have a common
vision let us now put people first
everywhere and I think
once again for your leadership Thank You
Antonio
obrigada and now we turn to someone who
has dedicated his whole career to global
health initiatives for the World Health
Organization director-general dr. tetras
dr. terrace it is good to have you with
us on this quest please take the floor
colleagues and friends ten days ago
President underline president Makram
Melinda Gates and I launched the ESET
accelerator a call to action to work
together in an unprecedented way to
tackle this unprecedented crisis i time
president wonderland for her leadership
in hosting this event and for this
incredible demonstration of global
solidarity the world is facing an
unprecedented public health crisis but
we're better positioned than any humans
in history to confront it with the two
weeks of the first cases being reported
to that nature the world knew the
general sequence the genetic sequence of
the virus
the first diagnostics followed within
days we already have results from some
trials of therapeutics and several boxes
are now in human trials the accelerator
represents a unique commitment to work
together at record speed to develop
essential tools to prevent detect and
treat copied knives in but the ultimate
measure of success will not be how fast
we can develop tools it will be how
equally we can distribute them none of
us can accept a world in which some
people are
while others remain exposed this is an
opportunity not only to defeat a common
enemy but to forge a common future a
future in which all people enjoy the
right to the highest attainable standard
of Health and the products that right
health for all I am my intervention by
thanking the Commission today thank you
thank you dr. Ted Rose and now I will
come our co-leads
in protocol order the colleagues who
have been working very closely with us
to get this initiative of the ground and
to reach out to partners and I'm
delighted to start with France France
has been the strongest voice in the call
for action for vaccine ten days ago with
the World Health Organization
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
epidemiology let me bless the planets to
know the weapons let's use OMG
I love limo the system the sorted on the
partner that we can redeem Adam the
President did a commission of a pen I
can see merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
Monsieur president mercy manual tooth so
suit yeah I said no blockers and now we
go from Paris to Berlin Germany has been
from the very beginning one of the
strongest supporters of this initiative
and I'm delighted to welcome the
Chancellor Angela Merkel angular tuned
as to buy owns pissed
- hasta swap them yes identity Basel I
leave a colleague on finder
it's been there for words of Utah
transmits by these are conference table
is sue Zion then the psyched ions ignite
a half nonk in Zoosh fearing student
fulfill Elena
Owens act once the seized upon Damian a
global a house for drunk is one tough
visitors have no global busy Incan
holiday at the mid throat inflictions it
isn't seal commands I'm and I'm
interests of Tibetan MIDI comment about
sustain on diagnostic emitter on
Deutschland if say again toss about so I
going to buy tickets once a child is a
victim aapke gaben see to anger Jian see
if a cop on mi an article sent this
photo inland product savage or deepen
the Commission's president and also la
fonda and there's a damn porosity in it
sativa a griffon hot October about
simple leaders and improve our tandem
stiff tongues by Saddam Sunni Mizpah
danke me but every how oh and Ben infant
nuts you own the cities of Armstrong's
Owen Tosh doesn't what does via yet
sprites and of Neuer via gets again be
Emerson fleshing taking the tests for me
please
Fila mention of the vegetarian partner
shaft
in space on limits on zan africana
students joined about midfield and then
done the missin Norvig again - Tom gate
I know that sin instructs and weaken in
about lights at the auction the products
your own font isn't interests of what
super I want via tuned this other sauce
I am the minds on series field mentioned
because on Titan angers it's ionization
fund me doctrines it ISM seals afflicted
the Avedon own Smith from phone at
Furman Spanish million and direct and
these are pledging conference battalion
of event also far from ready globally
the sunset in schizont
with advance come out ima yarn over our
fighter humans I awareness ungodly get
only auspi and his casualty its systems
that Erica is finding and fear in Lenin
there the students want the event opens
Oh humanity right here for hoon their
business is offending me
trauma two shows welcome had so much
given there and found rashanda's and
Africa yet see Malaya Hong Kong's unum I
saw the shanty the whiskey's Aparna me
oz kahlúa and some few few thirty guards
knew a kiss upon your missus infinities
and outside and there vanished Emma
multi lots of a suit Saddam Albert and
which made us venture a gun spectacle
signal whereas understood near half noon
each tonka eng Dubailand
Deutschland thirty StarCraft II and
bring Alice for for dissing the sneaky
let's the conference want us not me
understand Matisse Indian helps a
shindig vielen dank for bundeskanzler on
finding Angela this is behind open just
keep them strong couscous actors has
kept it off knock and how from Germany
we go to Tokyo I'm happy to introduce a
message from the Prime Minister of Japan
Abba shin-soo
[Music]
Pandya lion-o cheering Joe doronina sama
Saqqara sin data crow novelist Oh No
track a new Maharaja Hari concave on o
Kesava TNG Guatemala's Nippon dr. von
der Leyen inch oh no initiative or chip
cinemas corner restaurant rockin Eve are
excited chatter Terry
Gaurav oregano sin techne true convict
Eva joohyuk Latino hair salon oakarina
access so stay true joke agendas
portulaca in Okinawa Jenkins Luud a
tankini watch Julia choose Georgia you
are lucky no Kara you sin Cara's nipple
Cox a technical communication toaster
Copenhagen e tsuzuku yahoo Pattinson
otro no co-op names paranoia CPOE be
debited sista chronolock Tino hiya Tony
test oh yeah neaten sonya code or no sin
T no Kasuga kumaras kora kora Maharaja
Nina city obukhov enticed centrist esta
loco loco en Sita's que estos números
director say you boys I tell me pundit
Rosetta I began cetera Jin daughter
Cassandra supposed okra vintage
mucho apoyo see this joking kiyoka dice
que todo y nosotros day yo Co Co Co Co
GN o te o chão salesmen re
son young dudes right window chose
mediums Trudeau Kofi Annan tada
Cochran no windows appear anymore
kotero today tsuzuku Jill go ten o clock
will Co Graham's mother King two centers
there but no Co psychology
Sanga mathematically Illinois be Susan
Koeppen types eating Adorno hyo-joo
Chateau you know just sort of Touhou
dishes taka taka not trans in short I
Sofia
okay II do system no pure point has to
the scene whoa she's mad
Sarang since you Julian of the local
silk a technician or today's master Nadi
second Auto Djokovic who can either be
another cause yo
decision Tojo causes society Danny yeah
Kokoro persisted global Andrea sort of
partner tomorrow to meet me dentist
Atmos Corrigan Jindo 14 billion oceanic
wire con Connecticut either gin tonic is
a target in economy idea
Taoism a cactus no joke when your kid
keziah cuts down on easy cuz ii e co
teens to Tommy Keenan candy a GU yong-su
God or not kinky testicle Hani
multi-touch master canonical curie/nasa
Kazakh guides Lancaster
cannot see only Claudia vasenka pedasi
in theta ms n Union Tokyo Olympic
current equal take a walk
Jindo mezzo no Cheney which cut across
the state line and ethnic and gender
crisis religious area tourists
a legato gozaimasu from East Asia we go
to northern Europe
the land of the many fjords and the
Midnight Sun from Norway Prime Minister
Erna Solberg is with us Anna I'm so
happy that you can join us please take
the floor everyone this conference is an
expression of one key fact that global
health crisis can only be pushed back
through solidarity and through
partnerships between governments strong
multilateral organizations civil society
and the private sector as long as the
virus is active somewhere we are at risk
everywhere to protect ourselves we must
in fact protect each other so today
marks the turning points in how we can
combat the epidemic this is the
beginning of a global movement barely
seen before so the partnerships launched
today we will intensify the search for a
vaccine we will strengthen the search
for effective treatments and increase
our Diagnostics kept capacities and we
will make sure that the achievements are
fairly distributed and universally
available these partnerships must also
be with us when we recover we should be
guided by the sustainable development
goals including the commitment to leave
no one behind
no way supports the leadership of the
World Health Organization without the
World Health Organization and effective
and coordinated response to the pandemic
will not be possible multilateral
cooperation is more important than ever
so we pride in additionally an
additional 50 million kroners to the
World Health Organization furthermore we
commit to support global covered 19
efforts directed to the poorest and the
most vulnerable we will develop a detail
on our response in the common weeks and
months nowhere funds the development of
a vaccine to sippy and will increase our
support the two
and 20 million u.s. dollars and we'll do
so together with other committed states
Alexis but as we all know developing the
tools only gets us half way in order to
save lives Maxie's treatment and
diagnostic tools must be made available
to all
garvey placing and vital role in making
vaccines including a covered 19 vaccine
when ready available to poor countries
and to vulnerable groups so Noah pledges
1 billion u.s. dollars to Garvey for the
next rachida prep period including 400
million US dollars to the international
finance facility for immunization as a
co-leader of today's event I will work
to mobilize resources and political
commitment for fair access and
distribution of vaccines so together I
think we will reach our goals of a safer
and more sustainable future for all
thank you manga tuck Edna and I hope to
see you soon again and we stay in the
north of the globe but we go all across
the Atlantic to Canada Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau has always been a strong
supporter of this initiative from the
very start and Justin it is so good to
have you with us
really ger to listen to you and your
message initiatives it extra' my concern
yes it actually actually suits evite the
extremely cheap or notice it is a real
pleasure to be part of this today I
think it's extremely important the way
the world has come together with an
understanding that a global crisis
requires a global response we know that
the safety of our own citizens depends
on how we keep people around the world
safe it has always been best but it has
been more poignant and more noticeable
during this global crisis when a storm
comes people tend to want to hunker down
with their friends with their families
and wait till it blows
over but we cannot isolate ourselves we
cannot hope that everyone else does well
while we take care of ourselves
we need to take care of ourselves and
take care of the rest of the world as
well take care of ourselves by taking
care of the rest of the world this is
truly a moment for global leadership and
everything that people are doing coming
together to demonstrate that is
essential obviously we know we can't get
back to full normal until we develop
vaccines and that's what that's why
Canada in so many countries around the
world and scientists and researchers are
pushing hard to develop a vaccine for
kovat 19 and we're happy to support in
those initiatives here at home and
around the world but it's going to take
more than just finding a vaccine it's
gonna need production of the that
vaccine so we can reach billions of
people around the world in an equitable
fashion we can't just have the
wealthiest countries the most successful
scientific countries have this success
and not share it with the world because
we will not be safe until we're able to
share it with the world
that is why this acceleration for tools
of kovat on vaccine development on
treatment on testing is such an
important initiative and why I'm so
happy that we are all a part of this
Canada is proud to be a part of this
our contribution of more than eight
hundred and fifty million dollars
includes significant investments in
Canadian medical research and
development it also includes
contributions to international vaccine
development through the Coalition for
epidemic preparedness in innovations
funding for the WH OHS work on treatment
and of course support for developing
countries we cannot do this without
thinking about the world at the same
time Canada as always stands ready to do
its part and were very much looking
forward to seeing everyone join in
Hawaii or somewhere syringe traditional
above the Itchy table the vaccine the
test it's looking at the first APPA only
with some psycho million dollar on otama
I feel a perception of development and
Oh Canada nonsmoker Metheny group
communication police innovation
operations its BPD me de Labarre Alexa
posted nearly traveled alone desolate
Redmond people a DDP on development as
adapt the novel it was a leader leader
in this ultra circumcircle opposite
opposite satire awesome thank you very
much a maxi beaucoup just in math see
boku o Canada and now we are heading
back to the south of Europe to Madrid
where I'm delighted to be joined by the
Spanish Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez a
true European friend Pedro thank you so
much for being with us
and we are eager to hear from you now
you have the floor Sona Porto's palabras
buenas tardes estimado zko legas des des
des des Tonya akela gomez rindy endo
como siempre evoke Wando companies Co
public amenity avocados / Morocco VDC no
ever enough a few unfamiliar a scary
ghost another person our sanitary okay
Kavya s time preeminent near the fence
al Caputo a few other Mia yep on the
spectrum Hoffman Tinian active or stores
the witticism theories and of mementos
and my career so I thought was idiot or
a serious
every Muslim matters posted either an
evil robot estamos haciendo vessel in
Roscoe
Bella prescient on a commission rupiah
una cocaína posible para vanilla and a
Mia Sara in the last phase of rapid oh
yes a qiblah Cunha's los tratamiento de
los de Acosta cosas en todo el mundo y
la guerra noticias que tenemos un plan
para poder lograr mo españa otra manera
Summa istick cellent initiative alchemy
spirituality be cooperation impulse and
Oh Eldorado tan importante en estos
momentos de TC goes car pneumonia MSA
sentido me compras en españa
contributors his photos content of in
teaching communists a rose in congress
amo muñeca in cuenta be US Navy Liliana
vicunas he sitting they think of en este
roof recipe a Coliseum Palazzo nuovo
Sione's M preparation para la Seppala
mia's yo uh nada
y además de la escena de trois tenemos
que our investigation cientific ax que
está ahora mismo kostos en marcha de sus
familias de apoyo hasta el incrementer a
produc CA Milla's de su distribution mas
a real contributions Freeman Sierras
espero que sí vamos todos capaz de creer
structure 'as de collaboration deraad
eras que pueden mejor are nuestra
respuesta ante otras enfermedades
presente see future as a SCARA robot
como esto los kobe air nose del canto de
plaintiff respe ho yo ma no es
invincible si no mas Lyonnaise
vulnerable estamos ante una amenaza que
no entiendes a frontier ck mess Danny oh
no sada cuanto menos Unidos este Mo's
Unidos pop Unidos somos
sin - de una mucho más fuertes Rendon
videos hace que pueden cantar con españa
para estar en primera línea de este
proyecto iniciativa que esta moley como
tambien presentable a yo estoy seguro de
que tendrá éxito muchas gracias gracias
Pedro and now we are joined by someone
who has been through every possible
emotion in the last month from the
United Kingdom
Prime Minister Boris Johnson as you can
see from his video he's feeling much
better and I congratulate him
his recent arrival I'm delighted that
the UK is co-hosting the summit and
joining forces with all of you against
our common enemy the coronavirus in our
own countries we've taken extraordinary
measures asking our people to accept
sweeping restrictions on their way of
life and by doing so we've formed a
human shield around our health systems
enabling our heroic health workers to
save many lives including my own but the
truth is that none of us can succeed
alone to win this battle we must work
together to build an impregnable shield
around all our people and that can only
be achieved by developing and mass
producing a vaccine the more we pull
together and share our expertise the
faster our scientists will succeed the
UK is the biggest donor to the efforts
of the coalition for epidemic
preparedness innovations to find a
vaccine we have committed up to seven
hundred and forty-four million pounds to
the global response to coronavirus
including our pledge of three hundred
and eighty eight million for the vital
research and development of vaccines
treatments and tests and that is the
focus of today's conference and through
Gabby the global vaccine alliance were
also helping the world's poorest
countries cope with the virus I look
forward to welcoming many of you to
Gabby's global vaccine summit which the
UK is hosting on 4th of June when we do
find a vaccine it's vital that we are
able to distribute it to everyone who
needs it countries and pharmaceutical
companies will need to work together
with an approach that defies the usual
ways of operating we will need
innovative partnerships like the one
between Astra Zeneca and the University
of Oxford and will need a truly global
effort because no one country and no one
pharmaceutical company will be able to
do this alone
the race to discover the vaccine to
defeat this virus is not a competition
between countries but the most urgent
shared endeavor of our lifetimes its
humanity against the virus we're in this
together but together we will prevail
thank you so much I'm so grateful to the
United Kingdom for this encouraging
message and their generosity and now we
turn to the g20 presidency Saudi Arabia
I have a message from the Minister of
Health dr. talvik even for an alpha pia
i would like to extend our appreciation
to the european commission co-leads
and international organisations for
coming together and engaging in this
high-level pledging marathon on behalf
of the kingdoms for Arabia g20
presidency it gives me a great honor to
partake in such a tremendous and
impactful event we have suffered grave
losses due to this pandemic potata has
also demonstrated our humanity and today
is approved that through our solidarity
and commitment we can fight this
pandemic together in a summit on the
26th of March g20 leaders have committed
to closing this health financing gap and
invited all countries NGOs and
philanthropic organizations to join
these efforts the global preparedness
monitoring board estimated an initial
eight billion dollars to make up for the
immediate global health funding
shortfalls as such the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia has pledged 500 million dollars
and is urging all members and
organizations to commit to empowering
global solidarity in bridging direct
funding gaps and this event
you must keep in mind the importance of
safeguarding everyone's health globally
as we face this crisis with catastrophic
effects on people's lives and well-being
this pledge is urgently needed to ensure
development and deployment of
Diagnostics theoretics and vaccine
globally the wh o CP Gavi fine
therapeutics accelerator and other
renowned organizations will be enabled
to provide the support needed to all
countries to put this pandemic behind us
enclosing overcoming this crisis
requires an urgent and exceptional
global response our primary
responsibility is to ensure that our
people are protected from disease and to
make all efforts necessary to eliminate
it thank you
shukran shukran Saudi Arabia as you have
seen from the first round of speakers
this is a truly global effort we're
launching today in the face of the
pandemic we do this pledging to make
sure that a future vaccine is accessible
to all we've made a fantastic start and
I'm happy to have now with us two
special guests who speak on behalf of
regions that need our support for Jordan
and the region His Majesty King Abdullah
Your Majesty it is an honor to have you
with us your excellencies dear friends
it is a privilege to be part of this
global effort to respond to covered my
team and we truly appreciate the --use
leading role in promoting global
solidarity to counter this endemic the
past months dealing with co19 have shown
us that we all need each other to
survive the lessons we learn must help
us seek a better integration of our
world
rhe globalization that sees relations
based on building capacities
after incorporation and putting the
well-being of all peoples first all new
so only through this integration can we
bring about a positive interdependence
tapping into skills and resources across
national boundaries and this will enable
us to expedite the process of finding
solutions and addressing shortages in
each country in medical equipment and
supplies we will be better able to live
up to our responsibilities as an
international community to ensure every
individual across countries and
continents has equal and equitable
access to a vaccine once available in my
region failure is not an option with
ongoing crises conflict and unemployment
the risks are way too high and we cannot
forget that those that are most
vulnerable in such difficult times are
people such as refugees and displaced
communities Jordan protecting refugees
from covert 19 is a priority and while
the lockdown has exasperated our
economic difficulties our quick action
has thankfully helped suppress the
spread of the virus and this has meant
that we have been ready to provide
support where possible BP's neighbors
and friends experiencing shortages but
at the same time we do rely on our
friends for support to address our own
shortages such as ventilators and
testing kids challenges of success
increase exponentially if we partner to
build capacities within each of our
countries and more importantly cooperate
rather than compete thank you very much
Madam President thank you your majesty
my dear friend thank you for your
touching words
and now we're moving from Amman to
Pretoria South Africa is fighting hard
to contain the virus and covet 19
unfortunately has arrived in almost
every country of the African continent
from my last visit to Addis and the
African Union I know how crucial your
leadership will be to overcome this
crisis and I'm delighted now to give the
floor to the president of the South of
South Africa and share person of the
African Union Cyril Ramaphosa please
Cyril it is your turn pleasure
your Excellencies has the state and
government to have this opportunity on
behalf of the Europe African Union I
convey my appreciation to the EU and it
need to draw a preparedness monitoring
board for convening this pledging
conference in response to combat 19 this
is a health emergency of truly global
proportions and I think everyone agrees
to that yes developing countries are
particularly vulnerable to its impact we
require coordinated as well as
consistent international action so that
all countries are sufficiently
capacitated to be able to deal with this
pandemic we call on all countries to
make tangible commitments to bolster the
global effort but in particular to
support countries that currently are
bearing the brunt of poverty of weak
health systems and Africa itself has
responded to this pandemic with urgency
and purpose the African Union has
this comet response fund to direct
resources towards the continents
response and today Africa itself has
been able to raise 61 million dollars
from member states the money that will
be committed to helping to fight the
pandemic and as a continent African
countries are supporting each other
through regional coronavirus task forces
to oversee screening testing fine and
innovation to fight for mid-nineteenth
and them we pledged the capacities and
parties of African Institute to support
the global effort and in addition the
investments that we've made to be is
another research initiative South Africa
is committing an amount of water and
three million dollars or 1.2 million
euros to this historic threatened
country we believe that this is a major
effort and with the resources that we
have were prepared to also join in now
more than ever the world needs
solidarity and more solidarity the world
also needs cooperation to mobilize and
dyed investments and to drive delivery
towards equitable access to new Corbitt
Diagnostics
there are q-tips and vaccines and iock
strongly believe that working together
we shall overcome this pandemic and
actually I thank you very much for
affording us this opportunity and they
eat all go well thank you very much for
the initiative Thank You mr. president
Thank You Cyril for joining us today in
this endeavor and indeed what we live
here today is the world rallying behind
the same cause and many more countries
wish to contribute so
hear from them in protocol order again
for Monaco I have now the pleasure to
introduce a message from his serene
Highness Prince Albert Mahna Mahna
president my name is Judy chef detective
Elmo excellence madam Jamis you the
apartment above the personal portable
comedies nerve develop amelong signal a
twisters elbow still Excel sabbatical
compulsively OCD fab porosity servicemen
enormous person Keesha crew service is
an elite controller is no action with
determinant replicate kosterman novio
vatican mythology in unison or excessive
acid and a mini from Anita primo suppose
vivo in the party interference or to the
difficulty deserve my memories to France
sexual you convey the trusted novel
perspective a traditional socioeconomic
considerably cannot Ren said please do
on audacity reproduce solidarity set an
aperitif mahalo
set an entire a collective in solution
mondiale durable economy the parliament
we developed my diploma rapid diagnostic
vaccin a treatment efficacy so the tulip
a demon has to venerable lead on little
dogie artists and access equitable
technology medical social non-elite
control use porcelain repost o
coordinate easily there
tsuzuku only to succeed so now prick
inevitably more in mobilization the
hostess phenom share a little more gel
token efficient happy no metal point a
deploy the duty the diagnostic the
treatment in a vaccine efficacy
excessive to the population reported
appeared in coalition model in indeed
the login is a strong angel de la santé
Russa bill initiative the renewal payin
cash with the eunuchs a false ascends
actor Thomas channel issue the sector
public TV ad elasticity Seville who
organises that confer house they do not
not responsibiiity adagio motto no
corrective mo efficacy mo mo peloton isa
plasto no concertina strongly dementia
monitor Musa manifested Occidental
national precursor may sweat random agua
en la communauté internationale c'est la
razón por la que la principal del Monico
solidaire some girls only contributed
for common just Rican very loose any
concern in canoes even advocacy 12 kilo
McChrystal result Napa Dickey below are
some rainy news on a gunman opportunity
dr. Daphne there in what pretty horrible
a prozac recede just warrant a solar
mobilization de tus - ah merci merci
beaucoup attest merci beaucoup are
Monaco and now we cross the
Mediterranean and go to Turkey and we
have a message from president l1
[Music]
psyckadeli dollars 18 names in angelina
the moderator Looney upon cremated or
sunshine fund online salgan Amjad le
directeur a Saluki see at an Italian
cream it apart
sister is awesome vermeil item Adana
Penkala mm no salami or cabinet Atlanta
Maserati mr. Saturday
- F our inaudible number on Jack
Conover give me at churches in the
sister a bow video original system
Lusitania Kalamata new Buick Parvati
elector Frangelica
Sal ghandahar Tanaka baden-baden
de-stalinization
Taji derivational today is Ron artis
filardo tyrannical are sheerest an
attorney optimum not salvan Amjad a busy
job and I'm the Vantage dadada mr. solid
system is the ultra PR enormous boost
owner Armand Istanbul da which are not
keeping you see attack capacity her to
lead anonymous IP any salgan hasta
nigeria shot Rob Assad personally which
have teachers in the betray his metal
use coronavirus alguna site is episodic
Rizal Martin's admission CRC economic
via social voter Olin bezel sister
krisann in Tirana do less gusto pues
algum miss a diner Amy's diner a miss
Farr tostada hadera mission or takodana
hottelet mr. Wilke ol Eric Vaughn esta
página kadar
le dijo que sube Mazama desta soldered
macedon saloon Angelica da booster HT HT
s rule and critics out [ __ ]
enteric ended a gooey needle or tack all
Maya dev amateurs in general Mustafa
Robert Williamson
dearest Amjad led a rebellion Ida doe
Star Mazda perishers volition or tada
cauldron magician nata origin a shoulder
girl or Milla philately REMS any honest
ritesh's todavia ver SI tienes tiene más
en de que es el chavo da da detectors in
malta Martok abilities
JME builder jason de assonance DJ
cholesteral machine cannot solemn Atari
NWO began key coronavirus grisel mocha
Bella Tahu
18 en parte soul my des baux Nadal a
gravity Solis melodic galaxy sterile ara
varrock Rossio is in very moment see
head affair las manos e.coli last reject
comet on de Casas a trim in Sunland port
at model mulattos become non grata logic
Ashiya
carousel Irish immigrant Elton almost
very Kim Shannon Garrideb Oracle Mama's
parents even eaten Isla colon misil
sunday regional meadows hi Gary Stearman
abode are nominally mada kodomo Zubaydah
Larkin Trumbo so story the Catalina's
the Islander Millar a Cabinda despotism
is Malaysia Ellmers massacred our Ellen
a disease cremated austere soldier a
Mesoamerican HG limousine market analyst
erica
Dunamis each inhale our original Messina
Tammany door ami-chan Tim Curran
Cruz the pie - Tara
chasm militant Madonna secured a deal
Thank You Turkey and now we move from
Ankara to Roma and the due to technical
problems it was not possible to have
Italy in the group of co-leads but it's
a very important member of our College
so in Italy I welcome my good friend
Prime Minister gzip account jeez
thank you for joining this global effort
you will carry the torch of the next g20
presidency so please you have the floor
thank you very much
well release the global citizens dear
friends faced with an unprecedented
global threat the international
community has only one effective option
to defeat the virus cooperation from the
very outset Italy is a committed member
of the international alliance against
cholera dyers last week we launched in
the toilet 19 accelerator and supported
a call to action to scale up efforts to
ensure equitable and universal access to
vaccination treatment and diagnostics it
only wants to have a special role in
this endeavor
not only as a can't reach unfortunately
as Gatorade the lot of experience in the
fight against the virus and it's now
ready to share it Italy it's also the
incoming g20 presidency in a to 2021 the
idea one mandate we are willing to
promote effective multilateralism as the
best political accelerator to win this
battle by strengthening health systems
by providing concrete support to our
citizens and by forcing a sustainable
technical and a lot long lasting
recovery today I'm honored to announce
the following pledges on behalf of
Italian people who will contribute 140
million euros all the three
organizations will contribute 10 million
co2 therapy because the main research to
find a vaccine we also contribute 10
meters due to the World Health
Organization to continue supporting
most vulnerable countries in the
preparedness and response to Kovac named
team we will allocate our familiars
accommodate response mechanism or the
Global Fund and finally since the
distributing vaccines safely and
effectively must be our common priority
we commit to contribute 120 million
Europe over the next say five years to
carry for the global organization from
comma nineteen and other diseases dear
colleagues difference as a response to
intervention stakeholder Italy is ready
to stand by you on during this difficult
journey together we will make it thank
you
Graz it is epic Gracia and now from
beautiful Rome we go to the Swiss
mountains president simonetta so muruga
sent us a message
[Music]
excellencies ladies and gentlemen I
first would like to send the organizers
of this videoconference aimed at
coordinating a global response to the
covered 19th pandemic it is a very
timely initiative that illustrates our
common resolve to overcome this disease
together I would like to make the three
following points firstly as one of the
leading hubs for medical pharmaceutical
and health technology innovation
Switzerland welcomes the emphasis placed
by this conference on equitable access
to Diagnostics treatments and vaccines
we believe in the need to integrate this
perspective into all projects aimed at
fighting the pandemic
let us leave no one behind secondly I
would like to stress that the Solidarity
we are now showing in the health sector
will amount to nothing if we do not
compliment it with solidarity in
addressing the social and economic
consequences of the pandemic what good
will it do if we save people from the
pandemic only to let them die of poverty
and hunger lastly I am glad to announce
that Switzerland will devote more than
350 million euros towards international
efforts to combat the pandemic and its
consequences half of the amount will go
to the International Committee of the
Red Cross to help reduce the
humanitarian impact of the pandemic up
to 160 million euros will be devoted to
further supporting international efforts
to combat the covered 19 crises notably
towards research and development on
Diagnostics treatment and vaccines and
further humanitarian needs the Swiss
government will decide on these
contributions in the coming weeks close
to 20 million euros has already been
allocated to sepi
- the whu-oh and other global health
organization in this field switzerland
is looking for it to continuing
international collaboration in the fight
against carbon 19 under the guidance of
the World Health Organization thank you
very much for your kind attention Thank
You Switzerland and now we go to Israel
I'm happy that Israel is joining the
coronavirus global response and allow me
to introduce a message from Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu greetings to
all of you from Jerusalem defeating the
global pandemic demands a global
partnership that's why I want to commend
EU president Ursula vanderlyn for
bringing together countries from around
the world to combat the corona virus
Israel like all countries has been
greatly affected by it
fortunately our casualties thus far have
been relatively low this has been the
result of early action to contain the
disease advanced technology to locate
those infected first rate medical
professionals and a disciplined
population that largely adhere to the
mitigation policies enacted by our
government but as we all know the corona
have Birdemic is far from over at best
were only at the end of the beginning
and like all countries Israel is now
trying to find the right balance between
protecting the health of our citizens by
preventing and other spike in infections
and enabling the reopening of our
economy but ultimately to ensure both
the public health and national
prosperity we must all work together on
improving Diagnostics accelerating
therapies and ultimately developing a
vaccine I'm confident that Israel's
leading research institutions its
world-renowned scientists and our unique
culture of innovation can enable us to
play an important role in advancing
solutions on all three fronts and that
is why Israel is pledging today 60
million dollars to these efforts we hope
to work with other countries
to leverage our unique capabilities to
find solutions for the benefit of all
thank you
Shalom Israel so know we go back to
Europe the Netherlands were one of the
first supporters of this global effort
the Prime Minister my friend Marc
Houghton has a message for us
[Music]
on behalf of the Netherlands I would
like to thank presidents from Malaya and
her co-hosts for taking the initiative
to establish a global coalition to aid
the global community in the fight
against coffered 19 the present
situation calls for unusual force of not
a disciplinary and international
cooperation and for solidarity because
we can only fight this crisis by working
together and sharing our knowledge so we
are very happy with the actions the
whu-oh and the EU have taken so far to
coordinate research and innovation
efforts on coffered 19 a lot of work has
been done already but unfortunately we
are not there yet the Netherlands would
therefore like to announce that it will
be contributing a houghton 92 million
euros to global cooperative efforts to
develop and implement new tools in the
fight against the coffered 19 pandemic
we are contributing 50 million euros for
the rapid development of a vaccine
through the Coalition for epidemic
preparedness innovations 42 million
euros for dedicated covered 19 medical
research and development programs 60
million euros for prevention and
humanitarian aids 40 million euros for
economic stability for IMF and UN
mechanisms and 10 million euros for
additional support to the Global
Financing facility to be used to aid
low-income countries in fighting this
pandemic the Netherlands is also a
long-standing partner of Gavi we will
carefully consider our future
contribution and look forward to the
GAVI third donor pledging conference
hosted by the UK government's on June
the 4th thank you and stay well thank
you well Netherland we are really
building up fantastic momentum thanks to
the generosity of all of the pledging
partners this can really help turn the
tide in our favor against this virus and
now I'm happy to welcome a mess
from one of our partner organizations
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation is
an inspiring example how philanthropists
can help a global cause I'm very
delighted to introduce a message from
Melinda Gates right now the world is
counting on its scientists the people
operating electron microscopes and
conducting clinical trials in hopes of
developing a drug or vaccine because
that's what it's going to take to beat
this pandemic breakthrough science but
we must remember that's not all it will
take for life to get back to normal we
also need to call on our common humanity
covin 19 has reminded us that viruses
don't obey borders or customs laws they
don't care about what nationality you
are so long as koban 19 is somewhere
Cova 19 can spread anywhere so what will
it take to end this pandemic well it
will take more than making a vaccine
available to the very highest bidder
it's gonna take more than delivering it
only two people in wealthy nations the
pandemic won't end until people
everywhere can be immunized against it
until everyone can benefit from the
world's science
regardless of where they live that's
what this effort is about by combining
the world's expertise and brainpower and
resources we can attack this disease in
the way it's attacking us globally and
by working together we can beat it much
faster than if we were working alone our
foundation is proud to partner with you
and I'm pleased to announce today that
we will pledge a hundred million dollars
towards this effort I want to thank the
President of the European Commission
ursula von der Leyen
for making this event happen and i want
to thank all the leaders involved for
their generosity
thank you Thank You Melinda and Bill for
your leadership and thank you for your
dedication and now we go from the United
States to the ground Russia for
Luxembourg we have a message from prime
ministers of you better dear colleagues
I miss you but even if I'm not alive
there I'm happy to join you for this
pledging conference we all know the
Kovach 19 pandemic is a global challenge
that requires unity cooperation and
solidarity as the pandemic still spreads
across the world causing much pain and
upheaval it is so important for us to
come together to fight this common enemy
I therefore warmly welcome all the
global efforts undertaken so far and you
can count on Luxembourg support to
describe the response will contribute
five million euros to the central
Emergency Response Fund 3.5 million euro
to the global humanitarian response plan
as well as 2 million euro to the
International Committee of the Red Cross
appeal will continue to provide support
to the health systems of our partner
countries in particular in Africa and
the third region will focus on the most
vulnerable which is essential for the
delivery of vaccines and treatment in
addition my country has also provided
flexible core funding to wide range of
multilateral partners including the vho
overall our covered 19 efforts in terms
of development cooperation and
humanitarian aid will amount to 17
million euro of fresh funds and 40
million euro reorientation of existing
commitments but we have to do more my
country is willing to do more
therefore I'm pleased to announce that
both in the area of diagnostics and
therapeutics Knutson Berg has been very
active in the framework of several
international initiatives for the
evaluation of experimental treatments
for the Kovach 19 we are currently
running out
scale testing program at the level of
the general population on this we stand
ready to cooperate at an international
level and share our data on vaccines we
will contribute an additional 800,000
zeros to the Coalition for epidemic
preparedness innovations we will also
sustain Lea increase contributions to
Garvey the vaccine alliance for the
immunizations of millions of children in
the world's poorest country in the
coming weeks we will examine how we can
make additional contributions in
conclusion I know that together through
spirit of solidarity we will manage to
overcome this unprecedented challenge
maths is a VM SEO Lutz ANBU back up
north we now head to the shores of the
Baltic Sea Sweden is joining us with a
message from prime minister stefan Levin
[Music]
Sweden strongly supports the corona
global response initiative and today's
pledging event I would like to thank the
Commission and others involved for
initiating this meeting this pandemic
knows no borders neither should our
response all resources must be mobilized
both public and private international
cooperation must be further enhanced we
need to make vaccines treatment and
diagnostics accessible to everyone
regardless of where you live or of your
ability to pay and let me emphasize
Sweden's continued commitment to provide
one percent of our GDP to development
cooperation and humanitarian aid our
large core support at 1.8 billion euros
allows for flexibility and an abled
United Nations system to take early
action in response to the Koffee 19
crisis in addition Sweden has provided
15.6 million euros to specific covin 19
related measures and that includes 3.7
million euros to the whu-oh crisis fund
now more than ever it is important to
give the w-h-o the best conditions
possible to carry out its work we have
confidence in the w-h-o and appreciation
for the organisation's important work as
future actions these swedish government
pledges to make available 9.2 million
euros to the swedish research council
for investments in research and
innovation relating to kovat 19 and we
will provide 4.6 billion euros to the UN
Kovac 19 multi partner trust fund we
will also explore how guarantee
instruments can be useful for purchasing
for example by linking volumes
- better prices or securing bridge
funding it could be used in the
development of a vaccine Sweden is a
committed partner in the fight against
Kovac 19 our response to the pandemic as
well as the important work to enable a
broad recovery from the crisis needs to
be equal sustainable and based on human
rights this is a time for collaboration
and solidarity thank you Taksim Luka
Stefan and now we go to the very south
west of Europe to Portugal and Prime
Minister Antonio Costa Portugal has
always undertaken tremendous efforts to
fight the virus we have a message from
Prime Minister Antonio Costa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
research production and distribution
[Music]
[Music]
obrigada Portugal obrigada and now we
are heading to Croatia also representing
the current EU presidency I only welcome
Prime Minister and replan coverage and
they you have the floor and brain it is
difficult to understand you I think we
have a technical problem so I propose I
move forward to the next and we try in
between to fix that technical problem so
now we move from the shores of the
Adriatic Sea to the Baltic Sea and we
are going to Estonia and Prime Minister
Yuri Rutter's who wants to share his
message with us
[Music]
dear friends on behalf of Estonia I
would like to express my gratitude and
support to all Zola's initiative for
Europe to lead the way with coronavirus
global response as part of a global
community we need to act together in
this truly global crisis and leave no
one behind
Estonia takes over the rotating
presidency of the United Nations
Security Council in May we are going to
make sure that the pandemic receives the
highest attention of the Security
Council we all have a common goal to
leave this pandemic behind us as soon as
possible
we need new 10:06 vaccines treatments
and an eager distribution to all we call
upon everyone to turn eight in order to
show solidarity and help those in need
Estonia has contributed the World Health
Organization to support the fight
against kovat 19 we stand ready to
further support this joint global
initiative Thank You Yuri and now I'm
happy to introduce a life message from
one of the architects of this initiative
without you Viktor my friend all this
would not have happened for the global
preparedness monitoring board dr. Viktor
Dow President of the US National Academy
of Medicine will speak to us
Viktor I'm pleased to give you the floor
thank you so much president Lian your
courtesies distinguished guests
colleagues and partners a Victor's our
president the US National Academy
Medicine and the board member of GPM be
the global previous marking board it is
a great honor for me to join you on
behalf of GPM V and it's truly inspiring
to see so many nations coming together
to stop this dangerous pandemic I'd like
to think that it will the leaders here
today for their commitment and
particularly present online for
visionary leadership our 2019 GPM big
report recommended urgent actions be
undertaken suggest major gaps in global
preparedness on March 9th this year in
response to the call to 19 crisis the
GPM being called for an immediate
injection of at least eight year and US
dollars or 7.5 million euros billion
euros to support W Joe as well as
development of vaccine production
vaccines therapeutics diagnostic for
over 19 an investment a billion is small
compared to costs of inaction and every
nation will benefit from this investment
following the GPIB announcement we
approached several global leaders for
their support von der Leyen immediately
recognized the importance of this
concept and offered to organize this
appengine summit the world is truly
grateful to you first learn and to all
of you for your commitment : exposes our
interdependencies and the absolute
necessity of working together to solve
this crisis you cannot fight this
pandemic of future pandemics without
international collaboration in global
collective action we cannot let the
poorest and the most affected countries
struggle along we need to work together
to accelerate development of vaccines
diagnostic and treatment and to ensure
the resources applied effectively and
equitably so that everyone can benefit
from them regardless of their ability to
pay today's timing event and the access
to call the accelerator represent very
important steps towards achieving a
universal goal so on behalf of GPM V and
every person on this earth thank you all
there you can earn to this historic
cause and thank you Ursula for your
leadership
Thank You Victor and we count on your
continued engagement and expertise and
now we go back to Croatia
Andre Andre panca which Prime Minister
you have the floor it's very good way
better thank you
excellent thank you very much and first
of all compliments to you and other
co-hosts and organizers of this
coronavirus global response pledging
events as the rotating presidency of the
council we have the privilege to support
this initiative and also recall that the
first recorded world Karen team dates
back to the 1377 in the croatian city of
dubrovnik and it is amazing that we
still six centuries later use the same
methodology to fight the kovat 19 based
on our traditional strong tradition of
public health with Andrea Stamper as one
of the founders of the w-h-o and the
first president of the whu-oh Assembly
creation scientists have already two
weeks ago I waited the new variant of
the corona virus the Zagreb Base
University Hospital for infectious
diseases we are all so happy in our
Institute of science we are developing a
therapeutic vaccination project which
will certainly aim to select molecules
that handicap the corona virus by
preventing its entry into the target
cells for this particular pledging
conference more adding to the already
committed two million euros at the
national level for research for covered
projects I would like to pledge on
behalf of Croatia another 1 million
euros as a contribution to this event we
look forward to the extended solidarity
and joint fight to prevent this pandemic
taking more lives or any globally and
also in Europe thank you very much
Ursula thank you so much Andre thank you
for your ongoing support to our common
cause and indeed we stay in Europe now
and we travel to Bulgaria with a message
from prime minister Boyko Borissov
I was I'm also was a cooler you know
mean I myself Anna panda Mia NASA to add
secrets that tortoise Watanabe not
certain the pose now talk what - cool
he's a pool Avenue he touch code the
South Raziel over who Susie Anya
pinastri Kaminski G what does the
progeny put the coffee speed an emeritus
heating system II does the talk he
literally dirty Crystal Cove is Marin is
sealing Corps DeNiro shirako fat and he
said go Songo Bala not good
Otto Grumman must officially Donna's can
now see the partners on the tester Java
quilty not post Lobby drama systemic
illiquid won't permit be a hub porous
Daniel toes in a post not edge to two
years
nice tiana put crappy Emma they lost an
artist an open energy Fiona put crap
city Mellon Institute equal to her body
drop Amanda if second Esprit Kaname
bread they stood on a merit in ski tech
EP / entity which he quit were aborted
was born at the Dennis the odd criminal
neither too boxy no ill a car stories to
call it David nice
you have more leads a previous time at
work with moment ever pay to come easy
privy he is Khmer in the future but
search to Corona beer Russa so stocky
lady arrow
this is dominant or equal to me drama
and a boxiness to poet David nice Rob
the crew changes the critique me
populated the Bavaria in at a volitional
sue in a city call a of committed city
commissary widowed robotics and novels
are no-nos each chemo ecology in the
Java could just say future of Tasmania's
no chip
the bula vinaka Cubano vaccine ear
instead ketubah de la Morena vaccine
I chose Darwin and Alec are strong she
this cobraman
Milly Rd quit the put magnet in Georgia
Travolta zip and any non Apostolou mesto
chittim check cuadrado nina carries one
image for Pookie he does a persimmon
Derrida precipice even neuropathy is
thirsty table mask
Oh Java if sheet komoku demo test or
respiratory a parrot or odd open eaten
he tears beerus a boo-boo channel
qualification is a kiriwe number it Lisa
the gotcha procrastinate sativa sue the
waters of literally posture on torso
Ebola reciprocal eight maxie Boyko and
Maxie Bulgaria and in delete we will
draw a lessons from this pandemic crisis
thank you for your contribution and next
will join us Ireland with a message from
the Irish tea shock layover at car
[Music]
hello the attractor feature prime
minister of Ireland speaking to you from
Dublin accent seeds as we all know
viruses don't respect borders and don't
recognize countries and this virus the
corona virus is a shared enemy of all of
humanity and all governments the only
way we can defeat a global threat is by
working together on a multilateral basis
an Ireland and the European Union are
committed to doing exactly that working
together we can develop an effective
vaccine effective treatments testing
systems that work diagnostics and
therapeutics and in doing this Ireland
wants to play its part so far before
already contributed to 60 million
indirect or repurpose grants enabling
our UN and other partners to respond
rapidly to the situation on the ground
and as part of that we've quadrupled our
funding to the World Health Organization
to nine point five million today on
behalf of the Irish people I'm
announcing a new pledge of 18 million
euros to Gabi Davi
the vaccine alliance this will be paid
over the course of the next five years
so that the poorest countries in the
world will have access to the Cova 19
vaccine if anyone has developed this is
part of the European Union's
comprehensive effort to fight covert 19
we're also going to harness the
capabilities of a research sector our
world-class universities and
pharmaceutical companies and we'll
co-financed a public-private partnership
in immunology research in this area
valued up to 10 million euros over the
next three years sooner or later we will
defeat this virus will develop the
vaccine that prevents us and the
medicines that treat it and it's really
important but nobody in the world has
left - when that happens thank you very
much many many thanks to Ireland and now
we are heading back to the Western
Balkans I'm happy that Serbia is joining
us and prime minister and Abramovich
will speak to us and are good to see you
you have the floor
hello we're slow it's great to see you
and I'm looking forward to the time when
we will be able to meet in person again
and I'm very very happy that we are in
this United together United in
solidarity against the common enemy
copied 19 we are thankful for all the
support that European Union has provided
to us in this very difficult time and
I'm hoping that all of us are seeing the
light at the end of the tunnel I hope
your family is good I hope your country
is good I wish all the best to European
Commission and your colleagues and I
hope as all of us in Serbia that that
all of our economies stay healthy and
strong which is which is extremely
important for the for the time ahead of
us
Serbia is proud to pledge today 2
million euros for the fight our common
fight against coronavirus out of these 2
million viewers we are pledging 1
million for the vaccine development that
is to support the coalition for epidemic
preparedness innovation and 1 million
euro for the World Health Organization
to strengthen health care systems around
the globe we are also remaining a
committed partner to yourself personally
there are so as well as the European
Commission and all of our European Union
partners to fight this together through
joint funds but also to joint knowledge
research and development and
and all of the other resources that we
commonly I hope share together today for
Serbia it is an honor to participate in
this effort I would like to thank you
for organizing this and for bringing all
of us together please stay strong and
may the force be with you thank you very
much thank you so much Anna and indeed
I'm looking forward to seeing you again
and stay healthy and now we move to
Central Europe I'm happy to welcome
Chequers Prime Minister Andrea babish
who would speak on behalf of
Czechoslovakia Hungary and Poland
Andrzej you have the floor ladies and
gentlemen fellow citizens of the world I
would like to congratulate the
organizers for this opportunity although
I would have much preferred to address
you and the better circumstances it are
fortunately the world we live in is
fighting a pandemic unknown to living
memory in only several months the virus
spread from China all across the planet
and unfortunately virus knows no borders
it knows no nationalities it doesn't
distinguish between men or women rich or
poor I'm grateful for our citizens
acceptance of temporary sacrifices as
strict measures such a public Ettore
wearing fast face masks to stay home to
keep social distancing and eliminate the
spread of the virus were enacted Europe
remains one of the epicenters of the
pandemic nevertheless we may be slowly
seeing the beginning of the end of this
crisis as the reproduction number falls
below 1 in most European countries we
can gradually ease some of the radical
lockdown measures over the
and during the month of May however let
us not forget that Europe has the
benefit of universal health care and
high standard of living other regions of
the world don't have disadvantage and
the development in less fortunate
regions such as South America Africa is
personally troubling it is therefore
important that as the world leaders
focus our attention on the people living
in these areas the crisis showed us that
we definitely need to spend more money
on the health care we must work more
closely together against the common
enemy rather than race for the same
thing individually
therefore I'm glad that I can announce
on behalf of the V cigarette group of
countries Poland Hungary Slovakia and
Czech Republic a joint pledge of 3
million euro with each v4 country
contributing 750 thousand euro this
global pledging initiative will help
ensure free and equitable access to the
result of coronavirus research as the
vaccine is ready it must be available to
as many people across the globe as
possible during the coming months we
should engage with leading
philanthropies
to boost this pledge with private
contributions the cost of this
undertaking will be enormous but
together we can succeed let's continue
working together
stay safe and thank you very much thank
you very much and a and we continue with
Poland Prime Minister moravyetti will
tell us how Poland is supporting our
joint efforts in a video message
[Music]
Madam President ladies and gentlemen all
esteemed participants of this conference
since the beginning of this pandemic
Poland has been a vocal supporter for a
stronger European response to fight both
the disease and its direct consequences
as well as counter the impact we all
feel in our societies and the economy
that is why I welcome this initiative as
a crucial part of this response and I'm
happy and proud to be part of it my own
country as many others in Europe and
elsewhere faces the situation of immense
pressure to cope with the pandemic
crisis nevertheless it does not weaken
our determination to help those in
greater need so far Poland has provided
humanitarian and development aid to many
countries worldwide our medical teams
assisted countries as different as Italy
Kyrgyzstan and the US we provided
medical equipment and supported
humanitarian and development programs
worth 3.8 million euro in Eastern
Partnership countries reinforcing
medical and emergency services they're
supporting hospitals and other
facilities crucial to fight the pandemic
since last year we financed close to 7
million euro projects in cooperation
with the NGOs aimed especially to
strengthen the health care systems and
water and sanitation as well as building
the resistance of local communities in
countries of Africa Middle East and
Eastern Partnership in addition to that
we are also launching a new edition of
the Polish Challenge Fund devoted to
data and digital identity solutions
tackling the pandemic challenges
starting with assistance to Belarus and
Ukraine
pelant is also supporting the
multilateral mechanism by contributing 1
million Polish zloty to the central
Emergency Relief Fund and another
quarter million euro to UNICEF activity
in Palestine we are also in the process
of authorizing humanitarian aid projects
worth more than 1.5 million euro and
providing additional assistance to
countries in Western Balkans Eastern
Partnership Africa and Middle East last
but not least right now on Poland and
other v4 countries initiative we
discussed rearranging EU trust funds for
Africa out of 35 million euro we have
proposed to debt if to devote 20 million
euro to fight covet 19 in Libya one of
the most vulnerable countries we are
strongly supporting the team Europe
approach and devoting resources from
horizon Europe to fund research and
other efforts aimed to provide universal
access for the anti cavite drugs tests
and vaccine on the basis of affordable
price to all countries and people in
need to support it Poland together with
other v4 partners has decided to
contribute an additional 3 million euro
as part of this pledging initiative in
order to speed up the process of finding
the affordable medicine and vaccine as
well as efficient testing method I hope
that this contribution will be a
significant step towards our joint
European victory over pandemic and that
it will lay ground for future
cooperation on similar matters Thank You
Poland thank you for being part of this
movement and now we go to down under to
Australia with a message from prime
minister Scott Morrison
[Music]
g'day from Australia we're very pleased
to be part of this important event today
and I want to thank the European
Commission for bringing us all together
for this important purpose David 19 is
putting us all to the test and it is a
test we are all rising to this is a
great shared project by the peoples of
the world with a clear purpose to find
that vaccine for over 19 a safe vaccine
available to all affordable to all in
Australia and around the world our best
and brightest medical minds and
researchers are working tirelessly in
the service of all peoples today
Australia is pledging 352 million
Australian dollars towards this global
effort to fight covert 19 and to find
that vaccine we're providing 15 million
Australian dollars to help develop
covert 19 vaccines and diagnostics to be
shared equally between the Coalition for
epidemic preparedness innovations known
as sepi and the foundation for in ative
new Diagnostics find as well here in
Australia were also providing 337
million Australian dollars to fund
covert 19 research and development work
on vaccines Diagnostics therapeutics and
respiratory medicine our work class
medical researchers and institutions the
University of Queensland the Doherty
Institute and our CSIRO are already
working with sepi to fast-track a
vaccine our pledge builds on 170 million
Australian dollars that we contribute
every single year to global partners
working on the development and
deployment of vaccines drugs and
diagnostics we look forward to
continuing our strong support also for
Gavi at the pledging conference hosted
by Prime Minister Boris Johnson next
month and it's great to look see you
looking so well Boris we're also
stepping up to assist our region our
development program is pivoting to focus
on covert 19 especially in our family
neighborhood of the Pacific in Southeast
Asia where we can have the most impact I
know we're all hurting and grieving for
what has been lost and so much has been
lost but out of our grief and sadness
comes a strong determination to beat
this virus by
working together and in so doing
ensuring we are better prepared for
future banned hammocks thank you so much
for the ability to contribute today and
be part of this important initiative and
I thank the European Commission again
for the opportunity
thank you Scott Thank You Australia
you're far away but close to our hearts
and from Australia now we go all the way
back to Denmark Prime Minister Metta
Fredrickson will share her message with
us on video now
[Music]
let me start by saying that my thoughts
go to all countries who have lost
citizens to this terrible virus the
whole world is affected every country is
trying to do their best to handle this
crisis and no one knows when this will
all be over today's conference brings
hope that we in spite of the distance
needed stand united united in fighting
the virus United in endorsing the
concept and spirit of the global
accelerator framework the virus is new
but our response echoes our experience
no country no company and no
organization can win this battle alone
we have to team up share our knowledge
and solutions and we need a unified
strategic approach to research the past
has also taught us that investments in
research and innovation will help us
prepare for the future by now this
lesson is now more relevant than ever
directing financing towards for example
vaccines to defeat kovat 19 is needed
I'm pleased to announce Denmark's pledge
50 million-year-old in support of
solutions to this health crisis thank
you all for organizing this timely event
let us stand together at a distance and
bring back a better future thank you to
thumbtack meta 2010 mark and we continue
with beautiful Greece Prime Minister
Caracas Mitsotakis will join us now from
Athens cariocas you have the floor I
would like to congratulate you on this
very very important initiative it's an
initiative that really brings the world
together and joins our forces in the
common fight against the corona virus
pandemic today is an important day for
Greece we are glad
the beginning to ease the very
restrictive lockdown measures that we
have taken over the past seven weeks
have been relatively successful in
flattening the curve but we all know
that unless we find a vaccine we will
not be completely safe and that is why
discovering and proving the
effectiveness of a vaccine is going to
be one of the main challenges that we
will face as humanity but this in itself
is not enough a vaccine should be
produced in sufficient quantities in the
shortest possible time but it should be
available and affordable to the entire
global population starting with the most
vulnerable ones and needs to be
distributed worldwide on an equitable
basis and no country or region should
have a monopolistic access to the
vaccine when it comes to infectious
diseases this was also mentioned by and
indicates the safety of one is the
safety of all hence I would subscribe
with the call made by also other leaders
who have participated in this pledge the
vaccine whenever it is found should be
declared a global public good and I
think this is a principle we must agree
upon and I believe that this is an
important message that we all need to
send today from our part I am pleased to
pledge three million euros to our common
effort in addition Greek institutions
and private foundations which have
already strongly committed to the fight
against Kovach 19 will also actively
contribute new to the school alcohol one
last point I wish we can show the same
commitment to common action in
addressing what is probably the largest
challenge of our generation climate
change which also requires a
response thank you very much ha visto
Cariocas thank you so much thank you for
your contribution and thank you for your
support and now we stay in Europe and we
go to Vienna and I'm delighted to
welcome the Chancellor
Sebastian Coates Sebastian the violence
of the eine voltar to you and your team
for taking the initiative for this
global effort currently the situation in
Austria under control but we all know
that in long term we will only be able
to win the fight against coronavirus and
help our economies recover if we work
together to develop a vaccine and a cure
pleased to announce contributions by
Austria of 31 million euros and we will
support CP with 2 million euros
furthermore we support the work of wh o
if around 3 million in their programs to
fight coronavirus in Africa the Middle
East and particularly in Syria in
addition to that international
cooperation we are investing around 26
million euros at national level for
research activities to fight the corona
virus thank you for your work and also
for this global effort
Sarah Sebastian on film duncan
oesterreich
and now we have a message from Prime
Minister Hobart Abella from the
beautiful island of Malta
[Music]
the covert 19 pandemic is the biggest
global public health challenge of our
generation many lives were lost on all
continents and drastic measures were
taken to contain the spread of the virus
it affected the daily lives of most of
the global population nationally we took
strong containment decisions to save
human life despite the high number of
deaths worldwide one may still consider
these measures a success
since many more lives were and are being
saved the other side of the coin of
these containment measures is the impact
on our respective economies and globally
many jobs were lost affecting the
livelihood of many of our respective
citizens the lives of many people
drastically changed some of whom have
been brought to the brink of poverty
these hardships together with the
confinement also have an effect on
mental health the extent of which is yet
to be determined and although many of us
are now relaxing our national
containment measures life will be
considered far from normal and it is
very unlikely that we can have a swift
economic recovery until we find a
vaccine the elderly and the most
vulnerable will be mostly affected the
global management of the virus is of
utmost importance and those countries
with a weaker health system require our
support since the virus has proved to be
very infectious and clearly without
borders all countries need to have
access to clinically proven therapeutics
and testing material testing has proven
to be an essential tool therefore it is
important that it is globally available
and that there is adequate financing in
this regard secondly every day which
passes without the vaccine will result
in undesired consequences to human life
and the economy
the global economic slowdown is
increasing global poverty and famine the
economic slowdown could result in a
significant debt world far beyond of
those dying with the virus itself we
have a collective responsibility to
avert this as much as possible it is
essential that we start building the
capacity for the Swiss production of the
vaccine as soon as the safety and
efficacy of a developed product is
scientifically proven this fast and
large-scale production is essential in
order to avoid the repetition of the
chaos we are all currently facing to
purchase protective equipment
ventilators and some essential medicines
swift and equitable global deployment of
these vaccines is also essential we must
ensure that no country is left behind
irrespective of its wealth we therefore
need to have strategies together with
the World Health Organization and
international organizations to ensure
that the vaccine reaches all this
includes the poor marginalized and those
in were stricken areas to this effect my
government is today pledging four
hundred thousand euro towards identified
needs and partnerships thank you so much
palta and now from just across the town
here in Brussels I'm delighted to
welcome for Belgium Prime Minister
Sophie we'll mess with her message
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen dear friends around
the world Belgium will allocate a total
of 27 million euros to the immediate
global response to fight the kovat 19
pandemic of these funds five million
euro will be allocated to the Coalition
for epidemic preparedness innovation
with a clear focus on vaccine research
another twenty two millions euro will be
allocated to the global humanitarian
response plan of the w-h-o and of the UN
office for the Coordination of
Humanitarian Affairs pause for vaccine
research and the stabilisation of
infection hotspots around the globe this
effort seniors Belgium strong and
lasting support to international
solidarity and multi naturalism we need
to ensure bold action to alleviate in
the immediate impact of the pandemic and
to pull all of our resource in an
efficient manner to develop tests and
distribute kovat 19 vaccination as soon
as possible the ultimate aim is to have
a vaccine that is affordable and
accessible to everyone on the basis of
very sound material principle all for
one one for we all stress the need for
paying particular attention to fragile
situation in line with the leave no one
behind principle anchored in the
substation --all Development Goals
bedroom is a long-lasting host for many
global pharmaceutical companies we also
have a fine tradition of high quality
public and private research and that is
why we emphasize the need to guarantee
the quality of pharmaceutical product
used to meet this historic challenge
Belgium calls on a close coordination of
our common efforts with those of the
private sector this is the only way to
move
actively forward and defeat the virus
once and for all
thank you merci a donkey pelvic remember
that every single euro every single
dollar that we raised today will go
straight to the best scientists and
researchers and whatever breakthrough
rules have it will be produced by the
world for the whole world it will be
accessible and it will be affordable to
all and now I have the pleasure to
introduce Jeremy Farrar for the Wellcome
Trust he will also speak on behalf of
the therapeutics accelerator Jeremy it's
so good to have you here you have the
floor thank you very much and thank you
for your leadership and that of your
fantastic team in bringing us together
I'm delighted to speak today on behalf
of the Wellcome Trust welcome as an
independent charity to support research
to improve human health everywhere in
the world is very proud to partner in
this bold and much-needed initiative
we're clear that kovat 90 needs of
aberration and a leadership on a global
scale between international institutions
governments and supported by the private
sector and philanthropy Kovach 19 is
brought into the spotlight global
leadership and it's a privilege to share
a platform with so many of you today
thank you for your leadership and for
your vision for as long as kovat 19 is
out of control anywhere it's out of
control
everywhere and it's a threat to all of
us the focus until now of course has
been on the immediate response and that
has bought as time but let us all be
clear that this is now an endemic human
infection it is not going away this is
not SARS we have to assume and plan for
rebounds and for second waves the world
cannot go through repeated lock downs
the world is losing some two hundred
billion dollars a week to this global
crisis science and the sharing of that
science is the only true and equitable
exit from this pandemic then this summit
is a crucial step towards
a shared future there now future needs
that investment now
today has a clear purpose the
development of three tools diagnostics
treatments and vaccine and we will need
all three we cannot guarantee to have
treatments we cannot get guaranteed to
how vaccines we have to be able to
develop both I'm very proud to announce
today that alongside our initial
investment of a hundred million dollars
in sepi welcome will commit an
additional fifty million dollars to the
therapeutics accelerator alongside the
Gates Foundation and MasterCard and an
additional twenty six million for the
support of potential research and
capacity in low middle-income countries
that is in addition to the 1.3 billion
dollars we thought we found in research
for human health every year the
therapeutics accelerator will urgently
work 24 hours 24/7 to develop treatments
that will help prevent and treat people
with kovat 19 and they will save lives
ensuring treatments vaccines and
diagnostics are made and made available
to everybody in the world who needs them
on an equitable basis independent of
their ability to pay is crucial that's
why the therapeutics accelerator
alongside our partners at unit aid will
be a co convener of the act accelerator
global collaboration for diagnostics
treatments and vaccines this has to lead
to faster equitable access to all the
tools we need to turn what is a global
crisis into a manageable condition hope
solidarity multilateralism and a shared
equitable endeavor is the only way
forward and it also speaks volumes to
the sort of world we choose to live in
in the future in the 21st century today
is the start of those choices and
welcome its honored to be part of this
global enterprise thank you to everybody
involved particularly to our host
president Bunga Lyon and the European
Commission to help us bring together let
us make sure that the 4th of May 2020 is
the start of a new era and a day we will
all remember with pride thank you very
much
Thank You Jeremy it's so good to have
you on board
and we continue with the government
representatives now for Latvia Edgar's
linkage Minister of Foreign Affairs
speaking to us
[Music]
good afternoon from Latvia this is a
very special day for my nation as we are
celebrating the 30th anniversary of the
restoration of independence and latley
is very proud to join the coronavirus
global response and to pledge 100,000
euros to United Nations and to whro
efforts to tackle this disease
additionally the Lateran government has
decided to allocate 5 million euros to
boost national scientific efforts to
tackle coronavirus issues to work out
and to assist in working out the vaccine
also we are working to develop digital
solutions of tracking those who have
been infected or those who have been in
contact with the people
those are efforts that we are doing a
national level but we also believe that
only through multilateral efforts only
through joint efforts we can beat this
disease so to that end I would like to
thank the European Commission for
organizing this pledging conference and
also those nations who are participating
it and pledging its support thank you
very much thank you Latvia and we keep
on going again to Asia for South Korea
we have a message from foreign minister
kang q wa
[Music]
madam chair excellencies effective
testing contact tracing and patient
treatment are key to containing the fast
spreading code at 19 but victory against
this virus cannot be declared before
effective vaccines and therapeutics are
developed and made available to all in
need around the world the funds required
to reach this goal are enormous and I
thank the EU and the co-leads
for undertaking this initiative we must
all do our very best to stretch our
financial resources to contribute to
this drive Korea started developing
testing kits from the very early stage
and with sufficient domestic production
capacity we can now provide support for
other countries in need of them and as
one of the first countries to be hit by
Kove at 19 we are now sharing our
experience and know-how in fighting as
well as living with kovat 19 through
video conferences webinars and written
materials the request for which continue
to stream in my government has also
strengthened the policy coordination and
financial support for the development of
vaccines and therapeutics by medical and
biological labs many of which including
the international vaccine Institute are
part of global research networks the
Korean government has been contributing
around 15 million u.s. dollars annually
to the key actors of the a CT
partnerships and we will significantly
increase financial resources for
bilateral and multilateral assistance
and will make additional contributions
of 50 million u.s. dollars to the
partnerships including at Gabby's next
replenishment I'm also happy to announce
that Korea will start to provide
financial contributions to sepi and we
will also explore further ways to
enhance cooperation with the
partnerships thank you
Thank You excellency Thank You South
Korea we're now heading across to Mexico
it's a pleasure to introduce the floor
yo muchas gracias por la salle de series
consider Mo's plenum Entei con ustedes
tratan de hacer mexico toda so sista -
she owns de investigación y Gualtieri
muchas de américa latina yell carry be
fun tow con las que tienen los países a
Parsi pondo pues support our mo Rico's
Yo no sim en todos
muchas gracias buen dia Thank You
excellency Thank You Mexico and thank
you for this message from Latin America
now we proceed to the Gulf the Gulf and
the
least as strong partners in this
endeavor let us continue with Kuwait the
Minister of Foreign Affairs Sheikh Ahmed
Nasser Al Muhammad Al Sabah is joining
us excellency you have the floor it is
my honor to present His Highness chefs
ba da da da da ba the Emir of the State
of Kuwait who wishes you the best in all
endeavors
especially in combating coronavirus I
would like to express my country's
appreciations his excellency to erect
and see the president European
Commission for our great efforts in
putting together this this global
conference to accelerate the development
production and equitable access to the
new combat 19 diagnostic therapeutics
and vaccines looking at all the high
ranking participants in this event has
made two things here the EU maintains an
important role and a high level of
status and global respect secondly the
importance of collective efforts in
combating the corona virus pandemic the
State of Kuwait reaffirms its long-term
commitment to the principles of
international cooperation and
international order based on the rules
and regulations stipulated in the
charter of the United Nations especially
in these times of crisis I miss I must
urge you all despite the battle raging
against coronavirus we must not forget
our effort to support the people of the
world there are still the issues of
refugees migrant poverty famine and the
spread of other diseases this is
confirmation that the international
community must stick together and
greatly expand multilateral cooperation
in order to survive this global
challenges excellencies ladies and
gentlemen whao plays a decisive role in
containing the spread of the virus and
the state of coin will continue to
provide all kinds of support to this
very important organization the WTO has
provided advise assistance guidance
recommendations and support to countries
with weak health system
and how best to respond to the virus
they have offered strategic support and
resources in order to help unprepared
countries they look develop their own
national health plans since the outbreak
of the corona virus the State of Kuwait
has donated 60 million u.s. dollars to
support the efforts of WH o'the response
in the corona virus tried to threaten
vulnerable countries to this end I would
like to announce Coit pledge and in this
event endeavor to support this
conference as well as future
international effort combating of copy
denied epidemic of 40 million u.s.
dollar those quoits total donation to
support global effort in this battle a
monster a total of 100 million u.s.
dollar again I thank the EU and all our
co-hosts for organizing such an
important event once again I would like
to reiterate to his readiness to closely
cooperate in the fight against this
virus thank you shukran Excellency
shukran from Kuwait City we now head to
Slovenia we have a video message from
foreign minister ang a logger
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen coffee 19 has been
a test and unlike any we have faced
before
it has fought us how to temporary
strictly movement suspend economic
activity and isolate ourselves from our
neighbors and our friends but this
isolation has also taught us how much we
value human connection that we cannot
defeat this threat to public health
unless we act in unison we have been
compelled to step apart to prevent the
spread of these disease
Slovenia has acted decisively and as
thankfully succeeded in flattering the
curve of the spread of coffee 19 we are
now cautiously easing the restriction
that were necessary to protect our
people the fight against the corona
virus is far from power we must prevent
a recurrence that would once again draw
our economy and our lives in standstill
in addition we must all work together to
find more permanent solution better
Diagnostics treatments and a safe and
effective vaccine more than ever we need
solidarity leadership and common action
I therefore welcome this effort to draw
together all global endeavours for the
accelerated development and deployment
of effective Diagnostics safe treatment
and vex vaccines and to make them
available to anyone who needs them
Slovenia will contribute to this
undertaking by earth marking thirteen
million seven hundred sixty thousand
euros and government funding for
research and development and health
sector investments for kovat 19 I would
also like to highlight another lesson of
this coronal crisis it has shown us that
robust resilence an accessible health
system are crucial for normal
functioning of our society once the
worst of this health crisis is over we
must do better
in preparing for the next one
let me conclude by paying tribute to
health workers everywhere who have been
working tirelessly and selflessly for
the benefit of humankind maybe soon
prevail over this disease Thank you
Thank You excellency Thank You Slovenia
and now we move on to Lithuania the
Health Minister of Lithuania aurelius
verita has a message for us
Queeny is grateful to the president
under live for her initiative to all
states primer dollars and all the people
of goodwill to raise funds for the
development of the vaccine against we
Lithuania who has successfully contained
the first wave of pandemic well we
cannot live in a fear of second wave or
waves we need a vaccine we need a
long-term solution we need to our
elderly people and we need it for our
young next generation we need it for our
citizens and for all the people in all
continents we need it for our
civilization one collective actions only
Collective funded research will mobilize
our global scientific potential no doubt
we are stronger together let's do it
Lithuania with its creative scientific
potential is ready to join the
scientific efforts a to Lithuania and
now we moved from Lithuania to oh man
the Minister of Health of Oman dr. ahmed
el cid sends us a video here we go
[Music]
on behalf of His Majesty Sultan Haytham
Vampira the Sultan of Oman I would like
to add to thank her Excellency dr.
Ursula Bourne their lien president of
the European Commission for inviting us
to this important coronavirus global
response summit we very much appreciate
the proposed global collaboration to
accelerate the development production
and equitable access to new coffered 19
Diagnostics therapeutics and vaccines
that was launched on Friday May the 1st
we firmly believe that collective and
cooperative action between states is a
key found foundation in dealing
effectively with the threat against
health life and livelihood posed by the
coffered 19 pandemic bringing grave
social and economic challenges all over
the world we welcome and applaud all
efforts by the World Health Organization
the International Monetary Fund the
World Bank the g20 JP and others current
conditions in Oman we managed to slow
the progression of the disease thanks to
the measured steps taken by the
government and supported by the public
since we had our first case on the 24th
of February 2020 we've had so far only
2,500 six to eight cases 12 deaths 750
have recovered completely our great
thanks and gratitude our frontline staff
from the health care professional and
their colleagues from other sectors we
are fully committed to working closely
with every nation to advance common
thinking and collaboration among the
international community all for the
benefit of the future generation and
ourselves thank you very much thank you
very much
shukran to a man and now we move to the
car patience
to Romania we have a video message from
the Health Minister Nehru satoru one
deadline here colleagues ladies and
gentlemen
listen to be a part of these events and
to share Romanian support for a global
coordinated approach to combating the co
819 pandemic I want to congratulate
president will underline the two global
fight against the spread this worldwide
pandemic is a challenge for the maintain
bringing signaling change in our way of
life the world of our citizen has been
engraved economic connection have been
disrupted social ties have been affected
and our policy priority have been
adapted the force of this pandemic has
holiday has an important lesson
coordination and solidarity among us as
essential there is no other option of
ours decreases in the medium and
longer-term then thing the United
working together and supporting of as
much as we can with medical experts we
have a moral responsibility to make all
efforts to ensure that both and obscene
then one antidote to this virus we found
and let any future of that could be
prevented research is key in order to
develop a defect
treatment and vaccine but coordination
of Berlin importance we have want to
achieve commander when thanks and
long-lasting results in this sense we
strongly welcome setting up and dedicate
platform for partnership and cooperation
between with double staying and
organization to have provided medical
expertise we have to make sure the
access to innovative medicine treatment
and vaccine available an exception to
everyone no country no citizen has
to think or feel that you alone in such
crisis situation
Romania fully understand the importance
of this principle and value and I
pleased to announce that we join the
intuitive our financial contribution is
a month of two hundred thousand euro who
staying together
thank you thank you Romania Thank You
excellency and now we are going back to
the northern part of Europe we are
joined from Finland by the Minister of
Social Affairs and health I know Caixa
pecan and excellency it's good to see
you you have the floor
thank you president Banda layin for
leading this important initiative
your Excellencies our lives have changed
drastically during the past couple of
months in order to certain this pandemic
we must find solutions through port pace
partnership to deliver sustainable
capacity building for health security
preparedness and strengthening of
primary health care Finland is actively
taking part in the global efforts to
fight the effects of the pandemic in
total our immediate support is around 36
million euros this includes 6.5 million
euros in support of wh0 in addition to
the 3.6 million euros pledged to I F R C
UNHCR Finland bets 10 million euros for
extra humanitarian assistance in
response to Kovac 19 appears to the
dispersed in 2020 Finland is also
supporting NGOs with 3 million euros in
global kovetz responds feel fully
supports in Excel
of the research development and
prediction of the necessary vaccines
therapeutics and diagnostics Vinod is
today making a commitment to support
Gabby's work in delivering vaccines to
priority countries with 2.5 million
euros Finland has joined CP with 4
million euro commitment to pandemic
vaccine development and we have made a 1
million euro pledge to the international
vaccine Institute nationally we are
supporting with 6 million euros approach
paced
research concert him on epidemic
research including the development of
rapid diagnostic I will National
Institute for Health and Welfare is
committed to giving open access to the
result ladies and gentlemen my main
message today is this we must commit to
treating Kobe Kobe 19 vaccine as global
common good for health we must guarantee
equitable access availability and
affordability of the vaccines
therapeutics and diagnostics developed
for not covet 19 regardless of where
they have been developed who has funded
them thank you
Kita's Excellency kitters Finland and
now we move from Helsinki to the Gulf
again that is to the United Arab
Emirates
we will now listen to mrs. Reem
al-hashimi the state minister
responsible for international
cooperation excellency it's good to have
you here you have the floor thank you
very much it is indeed an honor for the
United Arab Emirates to be invited to
join this esteemed gathering and
contribute directly to its noble
objectives we appreciate very much
and Ursula van der Linde initiative in
coordinating our joint efforts the
United Arab Emirates fully subscribes to
the principles of equitable global
access to antique Ovid 19 tools to
multilateralism in the pursuit of shared
solutions and to the 2030 agenda and its
stated mission that no one should be
left behind the UAE is already an urgent
dedicated and responsible actor in the
fight against covin and we will continue
to work tires tirelessly at the
forefront of the global response to this
malicious and relentless threat as I
write the UAE is sending to covet 19
field hospitals from Norway to our
brothers and sisters in Ghana and in
Ethiopia we've airlifted more than 472
tons of medical aid PPE our gear and
supplies to 43 countries around the
world mainly in Africa first far a
hundred and ten million US dollars has
been allocated and dispatched for as
long as we are able we will continue
this work in cooperation with global
health and development organizations
sending the tens of thousands of testing
kits as well as much other much-needed
equipment to countries and organizations
across the globe so that they are better
equipped to halt the spread of kovat 19
at home we continue to protect our early
community which hails from all the
continents of the world through
extensive testing and contact tracing
programs
we're also mobilizing our medical
community to develop normal treatments
and diagnostics for covered 19 with
around 60 significant studies underway
among these is the recently announced
breakthrough at Abu Dhabi stem cell
center which has received a patent for
an innovative and promising new
treatment for kovat patients you will
find us always a proactive adaptable and
dependable partner we stand in
unwavering support and solidarity with
the global community and will continue
to support international efforts to
defeat kovat by working together we will
overcome this malicious threat thank you
very much for your time and attention
shukran excellency and
countries are willing to contribute we
continue with China the Chinese
ambassador to the European Union sangmin
will join us excellency
you have the floor
guarding never too modern for sannyasis
hui woman with four bases we each image
and male penguin Chicago to mingle funky
scientist article in dollar even single
fee and the phone which could easily
changing changing the coracle
Tony inherent or food from don t see
also India gender turned on to know we
change our countries in the new
distribution Tony Dantonio formula sheet
on the my future conservation GT Canyon
Tony Hawk OTT go budgeted stuff way u n
GT 3 different from millions in violence
Tom Watson found on this one until the
Banco de atacama teach the come here
Sachiko remain twenty confront Ebola
tagua are we and even today and tomorrow
for in the isn't it whole hog or three
with Jim you encountered food don't eat
it was a [ __ ] psycho circles in the
lemonade too much here the situate you
concurred on purpose the future from
either our github who Gigi's not so anti
it's important in life
[Music]
- Franken Shibboleth ie yo yo yo
America's own father nobody up in some
way English in the body for counterfeit
Anwar Congo vision t Sapporo Canada
which angel so in father no mother you
determine in the Adagio
Aoyama fondo de guadarrama he going the
charge on San Francisco father Nadia
senior year
trilliant Italy the campus attending GRE
week which is a week on a father not
even touch on
Anthony de San Marcos Oh Sakura Haruno
sitting 20 feet in height - Mia come on
three will be pinned hi-capa on medium
cheetah
quality comes out on the chair may
actually see Thank You excellency this
concludes the formal pledging round by
governments for now and we proceed to
our partners who all have a crucial role
to play
I now have the pleasure to welcome the
World Economic Forum it is the cradle of
some of our prominent organizations that
are here with us today
it is the place for example where sepi
was founded and it is a main link to the
private sector with us is Professor
Klaus Schwab on video
[Music]
Madam President
Thunder lion excellencies Hornets
participants the World Economic Forum as
the international institution for
public-private cooperation is putting
its full weight behind this crucial
initiative the purpose of the World
Economic Forum is to mobilize business
and to make sure the business together
with the Esso stakeholders of global
society governments international
organizations civil society and science
addresses the big issues of our times we
have taken the initiative
immediately after the appearance of this
panda me to create a coup with 19 action
platform more than 1,000 companies are
engaged and over 30 projects have been
put into practice we feel that business
can make a very special contribution not
just pharmaceutical companies and other
companies directly related to suspender
me but every business is challenged
today to contribute with its know-how
address its resources to the solution of
this challenge of this problem which is
of utmost significance for the future of
humankind we are particularly committed
to this initiative since the forum has
been at the origin in its annual meeting
in Davos of the Global Fund Gavi and CP
together with the Gates Foundation and
other founders of social organizations
particularly today Madam President
excellencies we would like to assure you
that business as far as a firm can
mobilize it
is behind this initiative and we will
support you in any way we can
Thank You Klaus and thank you to the
World Economic Forum now for the
European Investment Bank I have the
pleasure to welcome the president vana
Hoya with his message
[Music]
let me thank president of left underline
sedan shall Michelle secretary-general
Antonia cherish and store eh Oh
director-general dr. Taylor's for
convening this conference the Abbey has
been fully mobilized in the European
efforts to minimize the devastating
impact of this pandemic providing
financing for the economy health systems
and R&D efforts at global level for the
health and life science sectors the
Abbey has built with partners a pipeline
of projects around six billion euros of
financing with a significant global
focus on health preparedness and
diagnostics of particular note we
recently approved in 180 million
guarantee facility for garvey to ensure
access to vaccines for the poorest
yabby has teamed up with the European
Commission to build and finance a
problem of over 20 European innovative
companies with promising projects
against Kovach 19 for a total potential
financing volume of around 770 million
euro the coming days we will examine the
four pillars identified until this
project effort in detail and get back to
you with concrete projects and figures
and a pillar 1 I can already play
indicative amount of 141 million euro
from yabbies own resources for Kovach 19
vaccine development we shall look at
Diagnostics therapeutics and our global
support to health systems in the coming
days including our close cooperation
with WHL and return to you with a
comprehensive figure the group stands
ready to play an important role last
Friday
understanding to enhance cooperation
even further start with health projects
in vulnerable countries with the support
of the EU Commission and the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation the EU Bank has
launched the African health diagnostic
platform to improve diagnostic services
for low-income populations
and they're also contact with Wellcome
Trust by the potential collaboration for
the covert 19 accelerator we can't do
more thank you very much
finding vana hiya and thank you very
much to the European Investment Bank and
now we move on to the World Bank we are
joined by Annette Dixon vice president
for human development thank you for
being with us
you have the floor now thank you it's an
honor to be joining you here today on
behalf of the World Bank Group we would
like to thank all of the leaders and
partners here for your commitment to
delivering the therapeutics and vaccines
that are so urgently needed for the
world to overcome this pandemic the
World Bank is proud to be working
closely with partners as part of this
international alliance to fight covert
19 fair and equitable access to vaccines
for the poorest and most vulnerable
countries is essential to altering the
course of this devastating pandemic the
World Bank is currently delivering the
largest and fastest emergency response
operations in our entire history
supporting development developing
countries in every region of the world
to manage the impacts of covert 19
through our financial technical and
advisory support we are helping
developing countries to strengthen their
pandemic response and health care
systems which is vital for the effective
distribution and delivery of vaccines
vaccines diagnostics and therapeutics
are also central a central pillar of
this support complementing the pledges
announced here today and as previously
announced over the next 15 months the
World Bank Group will be providing up to
160 billion dollars in financing to
support developing countries with the
health economic and social impacts of
covert 19 including 50 billion dollars
in grants and highly concessional terms
through Ida
funds for the poorest countries together
we must ensure that the poorest
countries are not left behind and that
any vaccines that are available are
widely accessible especially for the
most vulnerable thank you Thank You
Annette and thanks very much to all of
you it is so good to see that financial
institutions are participating and this
is the moment to announce that the
European Commission is making available
an additional four hundred million euros
in guarantees for loans and together
with the European Investment Bank and 1
billion euro in loans provided by France
that adds up to 1 billion 54 1 billion
54,000 million euros in loads a long
figure so 1.5 4 billion euros we had it
alone finance for the fight against
Kovach 19 and now allow me to introduce
for the Coalition for epidemic
preparedness innovations
sepi chief executive officer Richard
Hatchett mr. Hatchett you have the floor
thank you madam president and thank you
your distinguished excellencies
colleagues and friends I want to express
my sincere gratitude to all who have
joined together today to express their
solidarity and commitment to fighting
the global threat of kogut 19 and for
all the many generous pledges to support
seppies work to develop vaccines it is
only through the spirit of collaboration
and through science that we can build an
exit strategy from the pandemic but we
must be clear-eyed about the challenges
that we face these challenges are global
they are urgent and they are unrivaled
in their complexity if many have said we
must remember that as we undertake this
struggle that so long as code with 19
circulates anywhere everywhere is at
risk no nation can end the pandemic by
itself no single company will provide
all of the solutions no one today can
know who will develop the most effective
seems or where they will be manufactured
but all of us will benefit from their
fair allocation of whatever vaccines and
tools can be developed we stand with all
of you with WH o with our sister
organization Gavi and with all of the
organization's joined together in this
effort in believing that everyone should
have access to the Diagnostics
therapeutics and vaccines the human
ingenuity and joint effort can create we
must work together the work will not be
easy it will not be cheap and we cannot
be assured of success but today's
pledges of solidarity and commitment
give us hope by combining our skills
expertise and resources we will find a
way to end this pandemic together now is
the time for concerted coordinated
action thank you thank you mr. Hatchett
and many many thanks to the outstanding
world of work of sepi and indeed it is
truly amazing how many resources we are
mobilizing this will really make the
difference and I'm pleased to have with
us for Gavi The Vaccines Alliance chief
executive officer dr. Seth Berkeley dr.
Berkeley it's good to have you with us
you have the floor thank you president
von DeLeon for your great leadership in
convening this important event with your
co-host and these extraordinary leaders
to galvanize these global commitments to
tackle the corona virus pandemic in this
moment it's absolutely vital that we all
join together at the political
scientific and community levels to end
this pandemic and the suffering that's
causing globally Gavi the vaccine
alliances work for the last 20 years to
assure equity and vaccinations we
currently help countries vaccinate more
than half of the world's children and
prevent the spread of outbreaks across
the world as we've heard from others
it's clear that if we want to end this
pandemic minimize the loss of life and
return to some semblance of normality
we need vaccines I must say I'm
incredibly grateful to our exist
and new donors who today and in the last
few weeks have announced their pledges
for Gavi for our next period as well as
supplemental support for this important
work on kovat 19 vaccines which we will
be doing jointly with sepi building upon
our experience and accelerating the
availability of billions of doses of
vaccines and the introduction of close
to 500 new vaccines in some of the
poorest most difficult to operate
countries yeah Gavi is now proposing to
create a new kovat 19 advanced market
commitment we're working closely with
sepi the World Bank and other partners
to do this this will allowed scaled up
manufacturing and speed up availability
of vaccines by efficiently managing the
supply and demand of vaccines with
supporting incentives for industry and
providing financial capabilities gavi's
innovative financing instruments FM will
also be used to finance vaccine
development by partners including zappy
and for the AMC this is essential for in
addition to the enormous task of
developing kovat vaccines we must has
have others have said ensure that there
are enough vaccines for global
deployment guaranteed equitable access
protecting healthcare workers and
bolstering health systems and in the
meantime ensure that routine
immunization continues during the
pandemic so that we don't face multiple
outbreaks of infectious diseases all of
this makes Gabby's work more than ever
and as Prime Minister Johnson mentioned
on the 4th of June he will be hosting
Gabby's virtual global vaccine summit to
complete financing of Gabby's core
activities and our work on the
additional activities we're doing on
kovat vaccines we must address the
crisis now and ensure the right systems
are in place long term to prevent
infectious diseases protect the next
generation and ensure that communities
can prosper I thank you for helping with
both thank you dr. Buerkle thank you for
everything that you do and we count on
you and we count of course on Gavi and
now for the foundation for innovative
new Diagnostics of fine
chief executor executive officer
Katherine Verma will speak to us mrs.
Broome you have the floor
excellencies ladies and gentlemen on
behalf of the Diagnostics community sign
congratulate s' the European Commission
on hosting this landmark event testing
is the first line of defense against
kovat 19 it saves lives it allows
economies to reopen and stay open and it
is actionable today
countries that have really been able to
test have already cut transmission in
the future testing will also be vital
for the introduction of vaccines and
therapeutics but too many are still
struggling to access the right tests and
these inequalities will have tragic
consequences we need tests that are
simple affordable available to everyone
find the foundation for innovative new
Diagnostics together with the Global
Fund is leading the Diagnostics pillar
of the ACT accelerator to harness
innovation and accelerate access wisdom
eacho public and private sector partners
we're expediting development of high
quality rapid tests manufactured at high
volumes and rolled out at high speed so
that we can test tests and tests this is
urgent for kovat 19 and essential for
preventing future pandemics every dollar
invested in testing today is a dollar
invested in our future global health
security the global need for Diagnostics
will be at least six billion dollars of
which two billion is needed for the act
accelerator Diagnostics pillar for work
that can save millions of lives right
now we cannot allow testing inequalities
to jeopardize our global pandemic
response thank you they
you very much mrs. Brimmer this
initiative will empower the
organizations that do the work on the
ground and together we're showing what
the world can do for unit 8 I have the
pleasure to welcome the Executive Board
Chair mrs. Marie Sullivan mr. when you
have the floor
thank you madam president excellencies
let me first thank you madam president
for your leadership in organizing this
conference and I want to thank those who
already announced additional
contribution first I want to recall that
the global threat of convene 19 requires
of course a global response because it
strikes everyone everywhere at almost
the same time the unique partnership we
launched with our key partners now known
as AC T is the best collective and
coordinated response we could hope to
combat the virus
we certainly need vaccines but before
they become available we need new tools
new treatments and better Diagnostics to
curb the trend of contaminations and
deaths now second unit eight is the
official convener of the XI robotics
partnership and an active partner of
Diagnostics and health system
strengthening pillars resources to
United will serve to ensure that
medicines and Diagnostics are adapted to
everyone everywhere in both the north
and south we will focus on unblocking
maken bodies to the products finally we
also need to ensure equitable access to
these new tools and make sure all those
who need can access them in that regard
we should learn from the positive
experience of Unitarians medicines
patent pool in making HIV treatments
available to most of those who need them
and support the implementation of
globine voluntary pulling mechanism for
Kovach 19 related technologies as
proposed by whu-oh and the president of
Costa Rica
uniteq thank you for your support to win
this new fight everywhere else we
together succeeded in the past against
other diseases thank you thank you unit
8 Thank You Marisol Touraine
and now let's move on to the industry it
is remarkable what industry has done in
this global effort and we count a lot on
you the industry to manufacture at scale
and that speed never seen before for the
International Federation of
pharmaceutical manufacturers and
associations the chairman Dave Rick's
sends us his message
[Music]
hello my name is Dave Rick's Anna's
chairman of the IFP MA the International
Federation of pharmaceutical
manufacturers and chairman CEO of Eli
Lilly I'm pleased to join you today at
this very important event of course the
impact of Kovan 19 on our daily lives
and our livelihoods is all too real and
never have the stakes been higher but
never before is the pharmaceutical
industry moved as quickly and decisively
to channel our innovation and mobilize
our know-how as now during the response
to this pandemic we are driven by a deep
sense of responsibility towards the
patients and society as a whole whether
for vaccines or treatments our companies
are diverting considerable resources and
brought together our best people to
accelerate the development of new
treatments and vaccines to contain and
extinguish kovat 19 we're collaborating
widely to ensure that our expertise is
shared across the scientific community
as part of the global fight against this
devastating illness to ensure nobody is
left behind and facing this pandemic
industry is committed to working with
governments and partners to make sure
that these treatments are available and
affordable for all the patients that
need them wherever or whomever they may
be our role is a founding partner of the
access to code 19 tools act accelerator
or the Act partnership is important
given our unique position defined and
scale of solutions to prevent and stop
Cova 19 but the development of vaccines
therapeutics and diagnostics is not
enough more than ever we need to
international cooperation to ensure that
no one is left behind in the race to end
Cova 19 this cooperation requires
coordinated multi-stakeholder action
that includes the private sector as an
essential partner IPM a members are
fully committed to succeed in this
extraordinary mission together Thank You
mr. weeks and now we move to the
developing countries vaccine
manufacturers network live from India
the president mister
sigh Prasad is with us mr. Prasad you
have the floor thank you madam president
your Excellencies global leaders
I'm honored to represent my constituency
today to reiterate our commitment to
global public health and to support the
fight against covert 19 the developing
country vaccine manufacturers network
were a public health driven alliance of
vaccine manufacturers from emerging
countries were firmly engaged in
vaccines research development
manufacturing and distribution in local
and for international use SARS cough -
the virus causing ko at 19 is like no
other virus we have seen before it
transcends continents and countries
class and creed simply put it's gone
viral our response to this pandemic
should also be robust
we urge global leaders to commit
resources that would enable vaccines
community to adopt a strategy which
considers the hundred-odd vaccine
candidates that are under development
enable technology transfer of lead
candidates to global distributed vaccine
manufacturing sites that are available
the TCB MN is a network of more than 40
global manufacturers around the world we
are exceptionally well-placed
to develop solutions for kovat 19
firstly code 19 many of our members are
developing vaccine candidates second our
members manufacturers supply and
distribute more than three billion doses
of vaccines every year and thirdly our
memberships have access to local
distribution channels and more than 170
countries worldwide which are actively
transcending borders for immunization
every day
we leave you with these simple thoughts
global product local manufacturing and
leave no one behind
thank you and namaste thank you and
namaste mr. Prasad so ladies and
gentlemen we've made it today is a
defining moment for the global community
at a time when we are sitting further
apart than usual the world has shown it
is standing closer together than ever
before and in the space of just a few
hours we have collectively pledged 7.4
billion euros for vaccines diagnostics
and treatments and all these money will
help kick-start unprecedented global
cooperation and it will create a truly
unique global public good this is the to
power of unity and of humanity and I
thank governments from across the world
for contributing with funding and
commitment and I'm so grateful to the
Global Health Organization's the
researchers the scientists and all the
partners who will work tirelessly to
find the solutions we need it would not
have been possible without you your
leadership and your compassion but more
much more will be needed in the months
to come
today's sprint was a great start for our
marathon the marathon is the way I had
now we need everyone on onboard I just
got the message that Madonna has
announced a contribution of 1 million
dollars to the coronavirus global
response and that shows that the global
response must also include social
society civil society and the global
community of citizens and for this
reason we are joining forces with NGOs
we will work with global citizen and
other partners so stay tuned I thank you
all and today we can truly say the world
is united against the coronavirus and
the world will win